هل رأيت هذا اليوم سوف
نظهر لك أنه دونالد
شوارزنيجر هو الذي نشره لقد نشر
رسالة فيديو قوية على تويتر اليوم
تتحدث مباشرة إلى شعب
روسيا حول أهوال غزو
حكومتهم لأوكرانيا كمواطن من النمسا شوارزنيجر  يقول
إنه معجب دائمًا بقوة
الشعب الروسي ، لكنه يقول إنه
يتم خداعهم من خلال دعاية
بوتين كصديق قديم للشعب الروسي ،
وآمل أن تسمع ما
يجب أن أقوله ،
وأنا أعلم أن حكومتك قد أخبرك
بذلك  هذه حرب لتشويه أوكرانيا
لتزعج أوكرانيا ، هذا ليس صحيحًا.
بدأ النازيون
أولئك الذين في السلطة في الكرملين
هذه الحرب ،
فهذه ليست حرب الشعب الروسي
شوارزنيجر الذي وجه نداءً مباشرًا إلى
القوات الروسية
، الجندي  rs الذين يستمعون إلى هذا
يتذكرون أن 11 مليون روسي لديهم
صلات عائلية بأوكرانيا ،
لذا فإن كل رصاصة تطلقها تطلق النار على
أخ أو أخت ،
كل قنبلة أو كل قذيفة تسقط
لا تسقط على عدو
بل على مدرسة
أو مستشفى
أو منزل
أعلم أن الشعب الروسي ليس على
علم بحدوث مثل هذه الأشياء ،
لذا أحث الشعب
الروسي والجنود الروس في أوكرانيا
على فهم الدعاية والمعلومات
المضللة التي
قيل لك إنني أطلب منك مساعدتي في نشر الحقيقة
ينتهي شوارزنيجر  رسالته
بالترحيب بالروس الذين يحتجون على
الحرب
ويصفونهم بالبطولات